während im osten der ukraine die
russische offensive weiter geht geht bei
uns die diskussionen um die frage nach
waffenlieferungen weiter schwere waffen
und das führt dann ja auch zu unmut
innerhalb der koalition und zwar richtig
grüne und fdp sind ja eher dafür die spd
insbesondere kanzler scholz dagegen sehr
zum unmut auch des ukrainischen
botschafters in deutschland und nach den
verbalen scharmützeln der vergangenen
tage hat sich die spd-spitze gestern mit
andrej melik getroffen bisher ist von
diesem treffen nichts nach außen
gedrungen das wollen wir jetzt ändern
und damit zum morgen dem spd
vorsitzenden lars klingbeil
schon morgen herr klingen bei was haben
sie konkret besprochen
es war in der tat gestern ein
abermaliges treffen mit hair make saskia
esken hat sich gestern mit ihm getroffen
das war nicht das erste treffen wir
haben schon mal mit ihm zusammen
gesessen das ist ein konstruktiver
austausch wir sind nicht immer einer
meinung aber wir reden in der sache gut
und bitte um verständnis dass gestern
die beiden dann noch verabredet haben
dass von den gesprächen nichts nach
außen dringt aber sie können sich
vorstellen das ging natürlich um die
frage was kann deutschland machen um
auch weiterhin solidarisch an der seite
der ukraine zu stehen wir wollen dass
putin diesen brutalen krieg beendet wir
wollen dass das sterben in der ukraine
aufhört und deutschland tut sehr viel
dafür und dafür stehen wir uns auch eng
mit den ukrainischen partnern ab die spd
stehe an der seite russlands melnik
sprach von spinnennetz und es gab noch
mehr äußerungen auch in diese richtung
an kritik konnten die beiden das dann
klären und ausräumen
wissen sie herr wenig ist der
botschafter eines landes das gerade
brutal angegriffen wird in der ukraine
sterben jeden tag menschen die ukraine
soll vernichtet werden von wladimir
putin das hat er jetzt mehrere male
öffentlich erklärt und da verstehe ich
doch dass ein botschafter sich auch
emotional äußert dass man druck macht
aber es geht in der sache doch darum
dass wir als bundesrepublik jeden tag
gucken was können wir noch tun um an der
seite der ukraine zu stehen wir haben
umfassende sanktionspaket vorbereitet
die hat olaf scholz schnee mit den
internationalen partnern auf den weg
gebracht deutschland und diese
bundesregierung
hat mit einem grundsatz gebrochen denen
es über jahrzehnte gab dass wir keine
waffen liefern in krisengebiete das tun
wir gerade jeden tag und wir gehen jeden
tag dabei einen schritt weiter und wir
organisieren den politischen druck auf
russland mit den europäischen mit den
internationalen partnern das ist das was
wir in der sache tun um der ukraine zu
helfen wir alle haben den wunsch dass
dieser brutale krieg aufhört und das ist
das worauf wir uns konzentrieren so also
nicht irgendwelche nebensächlichkeiten
die wir manchmal in der berliner politik
diskutieren ja gut verständnis ist
natürlich immer wichtig und reden es
auch immer gut der bundeskanzler scholz
hat sich nachdem es ja viel kritik an
seiner führung und kommunikation gab
vorgestern auch geäußert auch er hat
geredet man muss aber sagen viel
schlauer war man danach nicht das hat
auch der ukrainische botschafter gesagt
ein kommunikativer totalausfall
kommentiert zum beispiel der
deutschlandfunk wieso ist der
bundeskanzler nicht in der lage seine
politik nicht nur den bürger und
bürgerinnen verständlicher zu erklären
und klare antworten zu liefern auf klare
fragen schwere waffen ja oder nein
beispielsweise als er das bisher getan
hat was ist sein problem
es ist in einer situation wie wir sie
gerade erleben ein brutaler
angriffskrieg denn der mitte europas
stattfindet nicht so dass es einfache
antworten gibt das ist schwarz-weiß gibt
wenn ich manche gerade in der
politischen diskussion er lebe die sagen
ich möchte diese eine sache dass man
dann wird diese krippen auf wenn es das
kurz ausführen da wenn
wenn ich das kurz ausführen darf ist ist
richtig dass wir in dieser jetzigen
situation ein bundeskanzler haben der
mit bedacht führt der überlegt führt der
sachen auch vom ende her denkt der sich
abstimmt mit internationalen partnern
und es gibt keine einfachen antworten
auf komplexe situation deutschland hat
in den letzten wochen in der qualität
und der quantität von waffen die wir
liefern deutlich erhöht und wir sind
darüber mit den partnern auch in der
täglichen abstimmung wir sehen wie
russland gerade die art der
kriegsführung verändert dann müssen wir
auch die frage der waffenlieferungen
anpassen also das was wir mit
panzerfäusten tun mit der flugabwehr tun
mit der artillerie tun das international
der zum beispiel auch russische
sowjetische ehemalige panzer geliefert
werden das sind ja alles dinge die wir
international abstimmen aber es gibt
keine vorlage die man irgendwo aus der
schublade zieht wo man sagt so und so
funktioniert das
muss international abgestimmt werden und
ich bin froh dass wir ein bundeskanzler
haben der das durch denkt der das ab
spricht mit den partnern und der nicht
wie andere politiker die es vorher gab
über twitter mal nimmt in der lage ist
wirklich einen ganzen kontinent auch
durcheinanderzubringen der ukrainische
botschafter sagt nachdenken es gut aber
jedes zögern kostet eben auch weitere
menschenleben was die bestelllisten
anbelangt gibt es auch verwirrung
übrigens stolz sagt die ukraine kann
bestellen wir zahlen deutschland die
industrie war wohl bereit zu liefern
doch scholz soll den rotstift angesetzt
haben und die liste um schwere waffen
bereinigt haben ist das jetzt noch mal
eiertanz eine lüge oder was hat es damit
auf sich konkret
also man liest er in diesen tagen so
manches ich kann ihnen nur sagen in der
bundesregierung werden gerade deutlich
die mittel erhöht mit denen die ukraine
einkauft das wird im
bundessicherheitsrat sitzen die
entscheidenden ministerinnen minister
mit dem tisch abgestimmt das wird mit
der ukraine abgestimmt und jetzt müssen
die rüstungsgüter dann auch schnell in
die ukraine kommen wir liefern aus den
beständen der bundeswehr da muss man
leider sagen sind die bestände leer und
wir liefern mit den internationalen und
europäischen partnern also es gibt eine
ganze reihe von rüstungsgütern die jetzt
aktuell auch in die ukraine gebracht
werden oder die schnell für die ukraine
gekauft werden und das zeigt wir stehen
deutlich an der seite derjenigen die
dort mutig kämpfen die größte opposition
statt derzeit aus den aus der eigenen
koalition zukommen die drei wichtigen
ausschuss vorsitzenden roth aus ihrer
eigenen partei strack zimmermann von der
fdp und auch hofreiter von den grünen
kritisieren die regierung als zu
zögerlich strack-zimmermann wirft dem
kanzler sogar vor nicht die wahrheit
gesagt zu haben als er behauptete andere
nato länder würden das gleiche tun wie
deutschland so viel zum thema absprache
also krise groß ganz kurz
nein das was dort passiert was olaf
scholz entscheidet das eng abgestimmt
mit der spitze der grünen ist eng
abgestimmt mit der spitze der fdp ist
eng abgestimmt auch mit der spitze der
sozialdemokratie und wenn es den
einzelnen parteien debatten gibt wenn es
einzelne abgeordnete gibt die anderer
meinung sind dann muss das bitte jeweils
in den eigenen parteien geklärt werden
ob die bundesregierung steht geschlossen
und handelt entschieden sagt lars
klingbeil der chef der spd vielen dank
fürs gespräch
sehr gern